Yeah.
It's the stuff
of which fairy tales are made.
The prince and princess
on their wedding day.
But fairy tales
usually end at this point
with the simple phrase they lived
happily ever after.
Our faith sees the wedding day
not as the place of arrival,
but the place where the adventure
really begins
Yes.
Court
under the
command of Lieutenant
Colonel Andrew Hancock, those royals
Charles and Diana stayed with him
and his wife, Camilla,
in Wiltshire
on two occasions at the end of the year.
So that among friends, as they ride along the round.
Hello, Tom.
Hello.
Yes.
Um... personally, I think this was
nothing but a waste of time.
I think the money could have been spent a lot better elsewhere.
I thought it was fantastic
and really great for the British image.
What made it so special for you?
Well, to see all them people.
Yes, so you weren't actually among them then?
No, no. I was at home watching.
Very sensible. I should think it was pretty crowded
out there. wasn't it?
It was but...
has been marvelous.
Proud to be British by dear.